spider-man has wondered most iconic
costumes in comics but he has had quite
a few different ones over the years
we've seen many variations in two
different movies and video games what
people might not realize is there's been
around 20 different Spiderman costumes
in the comics here's a top 10 costumes
number 10 future foundations when the
Fantastic Four changed her focus and
became the future foundation spider-man
joined a team the team suits were white
you would think that the white suits
would get pretty dirty quickly but they
were made of unstable molecules and
could also change color number 9 scarlet
spiders when Aunt May was on her
deathbed Peter Parker's clone Ben Riley
made his way back to New York
Peter was unaware his clone was still
alive then needed a costume to protect
Peters identity he went the simple route
by wearing a red bodysuit and a blue
hoodie with a sleeves ripped off calling
himself the Scarlet Spider he also added
some new items such as stingers that
could be shot out and impact webbing
number 8 Ben Riley spider-man when Peter
decided to retire from being spider-man
and enjoyed a married life Ben Riley
took over instead of just putting on
Spidey's old suit he tweaked the design
to make it a little more of his own
having the web-shooters on the outside
probably made it a little more practical
in being able to change the web
cartridges faster number 7 spider hammer
there's actually been four different
spider armors over the years the first
one was basically harden webbing and was
destroyed by the end of the issue
the second was bulletproof the third was
used to take on Doc Ock in the sinister
six
the fourth is his current costume and it
is based on his classic look number 6
stealth suit when Spiderman had to
figure out a way to defeat an enemy
without using his spider senses he made
a stealth suit that could warp the light
and sound around him it had a second
area mode that allowed him to avoid
sonic attacks
number five Miles Morales Miles Morales
was from the ultimate universe and
became spider-man after Peter Parker
died he was recently integrated into the
mainstream Marvel Universe and we now
have two spider-man's or men number four
superior spider-man Doc Ock was dying it
managed to insert his mind into
spider-man's feeling he could be a
superior spider-man due to his intellect
he made a new suit to be a better web
slinger number three iron spider
during the first civil war in the comics
spider-man aligned himself with Tony
Stark who designed a suit with colors
similar to Iron Man's original look this
was the first time Spidey had a suit
with extra appendages it had other
advanced functions but eventually took a
pretty bad beating
number two Cindy a costume on an alien
planet
spider-man thought he was using a
costume making machine he came into
contact with an alien symbiont the new
costume obeyed his thoughts and could
change its appearance
unfortunately the costume wanted to bond
with him permanently and take over his
body
spider-man removed a costume and had it
contained with the help of a fantastic
four honorable mention the bombastic
bagman after spider-man was freed from
the alien symbiote he was left with
nothing but his underwear the Human
Torch came up with a solution as part of
a prank Spiderman was forced to wear an
old and baggy FF suit with a paper bag
over his head
the top spider-man costume is the
classic red and blue one every time
Spiderman went through a costume change
he always ended up with the class
as he should let us know which costume
is your favorite
did we leave your costume off the list
answer in the comments below